dude i think i have hope for the
homeless situation
in california you do yeah i saw them
cleaning up uh
this the freeway i get on the one-on-one
and like western all the time
i saw them cleaning it up yeah clean
them up yeah
but they have to go somewhere they got
to go somewhere and you know what yeah
these shipping all the venice yeah
they could go to europe they used to do
that all the time
anyway right so okay so there are a
couple things that that go on
one is that a judge a federal judge sued
i think
l.a or california saying you got to do
something about the homeless situation
in l.a
yeah so when you get sued like that now
they go through appeals and stuff
but the bottom line is there are two
things going on one is you got to do
something with the homeless so if you
move
there's a whole [ __ ] tent city yeah
where you're going to put them
you can you provide shelters but this is
what they say they don't go to the
shelters you know why i don't go to
shelters because they got a curfew
can't do their drugs can't do the [ __ ]
they want to do so you'd rather live in
a community
it's like [ __ ] disneyland go by go
down near gold go down near the mecca of
bodybuilding and take a look at that i
don't even go down there anymore because
they break your heart
and check this out you know you know the
budget for the homeless is a billion
dollars a year
california is a billion dollars yeah but
here's the here's a bigger problem what
are they doing with that
but now i'll tell you what they're doing
now look at brian yeah
they go hey we need you to build housing
for the homeless
well developers go really
i'll take that contract give me money
i'm building housing for the homeless so
they just
they allocate like a parking lot beast
front property whatever it might be
and now you've got a homeless industrial
complex because
all these [ __ ] developers start
bidding for those contracts
you got to build housing you're making
money so when they try to kill that
program
now you lobby the government and go
lobby sacramento you go wait a minute
you can't kill this i i mean i
this what if we just made like one city
a designated space for like bakersfield
well they have you know they thought
about their air force base there's that
air force base
they were they moved because they made
money hey guys i love baker fish that's
a staple for it
about air force banks base and they were
like move them all out there but then
they don't want to go well you're in the
middle of nowhere yeah they don't have
anything
do they need oceanfront they need
resources to steal like
people to give them money and drugs
drugs
so you can't really so you can't
necessarily put them off in the distance
bro they literally all right
go they live [ __ ] beasts bring up
venice boardwalk right now they they
they live on the [ __ ] beach kids my
like my daughter when i take my son my
dog they don't want to go down there
because because it's good i know they're
working on cleaning it up because i did
a show i did a fundraiser show
where there was like a petition to be
able to because
so mike bonnier mike bonin who is the
council member he had a rally for bernie
sanders he's a bernie supporter yep when
they had the rally guess what all the
homeless were gone how
interesting they were all gone and now
look at him how did they
and the minute he left they came back
that's nice that's always been venice
though a little bit not that really
not that bad you shouldn't be allowed
always i don't think you should be able
to i've been typing is this venice 2021
now
that it's kind of fun when like you want
a little trick of homeless and like
that's the street light
yeah i grew up on that yeah but now it's
like that's i don't think you should be
allowed to build a [ __ ] house
on the side of the road no well i know
the poor property owners are the
business owners oh dude
has it ruined the skate park over there
no no no it's going strong nothing's
booming
it's going strong those kids will hit a
bum in the [ __ ] states
those kids are all killing that [ __ ]
yeah i go there and watch them
they just those kids they're so good
i did too i saw like oh do you see those
uh what the paul rodriguez dunks coming
out
no you know who he is right you were
quick he was talking
you just said hey
paul rodriguez uh dunks the comics i'm
just i'm just happy to be here uh
see uh the first ones chin this one yes
he's the comic paul rodriguez no
no his his dad is the comedy his dad's
the comic though but he's the best in
the world
really yes better than me you don't
think he's nigel nigel
you know nigel niger houston's a beast
nigel's
rodriguez though rodriguez is beast he's
that good
bees i remember him talking he made the
dunks popular
those are nice
super popular brothers no one was really
skating them back in back in the day
those are dope those are dope you like
them brian i can't we got to get you two
also
not not those hey let's go to the
supreme
elephant i've
i need first of all i need some i need
to feel like i can sprint
these are reserved you know what i mean
they're because what's wrong with my
samba classics
they're into a soccer shoe did you steal
those from pete
we're like closeted yes oh my god you
could
no it's too much yeah oh wow you get
your name on them i know
you flex no i'm not flexing but if we're
gonna flex
i just whoa
gold dude and this
that's real gold you know what these are
no bro these are the
off whites no holy grail of chicks
well first of all that looks like is
that real uh that's
real alligator kanye west real gold for
nike they don't make him anymore
my boy's from suplex uh i sent him oh
i'll buy your tesla with these you be
quiet buy your stupid [ __ ]
how much are they it's gonna make me mad
oh yeah it's gonna make you mad i don't
know look it up
yeah chin they i think i wanna yeezy
what's
uh nike yeezys nike yeezys and and you
like them because they got this
this natural they killed a python or a
lizard
because no one else really has them yeah
no no i'm out there but they're fake
nike air yeezys nope nope those are the
no
so what's the full name that's expensive
i know he's already won no man these are
old school
dog god damn dog we gotta get you here
what year what year
uh um don't do year if you just go to
nike yeezy i'll find them i'll just go
through that i'm new to the shooting oh
right there right man yeah
are you kidding me that's what you spent
i didn't spend it 26. these were given
to me you could you could get some very
good friends
that's a very you shouldn't even say
this because they're going to be there
are people that will rob you the way
they took
lady gaga's dogs they'll take your
[ __ ] speakers sure and i hate to say
this
if you got your sneakers taken sure you
deserve it for sure because they'll hold
you at gunpoint and say
your ass gets on your ass take the shoes
off
give them up now and then you're like
this
i'm gonna be that disheartening for free
oh there you go
i'm like dude take it easy with a gun
here you go and then you know what they
do
and it's annoying that you own those so
suck me up
dude why do you have to make it that way
because there's no time thug want a thug
so they're just gonna be like oh yeah
dude why you gotta make it why do you
how much is robbing hey how about that
the guy zoo culture with the pink
[ __ ] do-rag today oh yeah
just a rough gay hood he wasn't gay
who wears a pink do-rag with white
fluffy
headphones you have a music jack wife
beater
pink do-rag just [ __ ] damn yeah
and it was just chess we all cleaved
that was chest cleaved out oh man
pink durable that man was not gay oh
what
you want to see
damn he'll grab him with a gable grip
and just [ __ ] go to town
i don't know don't if he's your if he's
doing curls like this
no he wow now hold on
hold on it sounds like he's hard so i
don't know why you're making them all
limp bristol
he's doing it he's not always was he a
power bottom or is he a power top that's
powered top yeah
he's a stranger then he's [ __ ]
jacking it up boom
he's a straight male that likes pink can
i be honest with you there are different
ways to curl
you got this uh-huh you got this and you
got that
now i'll go all three i'll mix it up oh
i wonder
he likes it one workout yeah so
tell this old [ __ ] what we did today at
the at the gym you'd blow your
old [ __ ] out wow your [ __ ]
apostate would go
i just sent you your video we did uh
deadlifts
i've done deadlifts where my my my
[ __ ] starts itching because i think
like
your butthole's like all right dude i
got hemorrhoids from doing yeah
chappelle farted yeah i farted
and we lined up so you do you do four
sets of six be a two minute rest
but so let's say your your set of six
took [ __ ] a minute you only have a
minute of rest
at some explainer like i don't want to
finish this story
it's like there's so much to it you know
it's just like yeah you lost a lot of
years all and everybody
see this that's 4.75
how much weight that is dude that's 475.
ah not a problem don't be mad at the
flat back either
no i practically done 10. god damn dude
so much weight and not even juiced
besides yeah he would just say that's
hannah wait what is annevar i don't
worry about it
but um my father my father 81 last night
yeah he's just
staying with you right giant man it's so
fun after yeah he's tall he's tall dude
he's six four uh and every bit of 260. i
go home this weekend i'm already
triggered
yeah and well my mom my mom my mom has
to warn you about death with everything
my kids are in the back seat as we're
driving yeah and you always have to be
careful because this this
story she tells my two children we're
going to celebrate my dad's birthday at
my sister's house and she says
you know um a woman was she had her two
kids in a car
little adorable kids and she was in a
rush and she was in a bad mood and there
was traffic
and she decided to pull out she decided
to pull out the traffic
and a truck was coming this way and
smashed her and the children and they
all died that was the story that's
you're not watching too much news
i'm a little similar your mom especially
i have kids because i read so much
serial killer [ __ ] and then i watch
first 48 and i watch the serial killer
documentary so like
when i came home from the gym there's a
dude there working on the cable i didn't
know guys were on the cable and then my
son boston's there with our you know
with our
uh girl who watches them so i come in
i'm like i take my arm like hey did you
schedule a cable guys she's like no i
don't know cable d right so that my mind
starts [ __ ] going crazy
i'm like well if i walk in he's like
grabbing boss or something like that so
i come in pretty hot
what are you doing dude he's like you
set this up like two months ago man
i was like what up terrified he's like
yeah he's small i mean like set
what up he's trying to fix your wi-fi
all right man all right
i stood there watched i'll be watching
you yeah you don't yeah you can't trust
it
my dad one thing about anyone is she
comes in and i and he's just you just
stand there good health
everything's good unbelievable dad looks
like far it's hard
your dad looks like farting come on i'm
sorry i go like this he's standing there
i can't remember
stand there and i just go
and well i went like this and i look at
my mother
and she goes she goes and he just goes
like this he just goes
he walks and then comes back more
dude i got my girlfriend
we all go we're all going and my mother
and he just looks at me like this
and he just goes and he just walks
upstairs to my mother
and i go look you know and my mother
goes he doesn't care
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he doesn't even
care he knows what he's doing
i want to get to that age like my uncle
backs when he's older you know
we had dinner just he's like so the
thing is
yeah i'm like hey i'm eating shrimp
cocktails bro i just ripped a loud fart
in the middle of the steakhouse
i told you about the old guys he was not
homeless just a regular guy like 80
something
and there was candy and he went like
this he goes
and it's coat pocket and i was like
nobody said you get to a level where you
just don't give a [ __ ] i don't know what
level i was embarrassed about farting
during the [ __ ] deadlift yeah
i was like
world star chin there's this hot girl
she's like on the track or something
like that she's doing instagram live
she's like chilling
she's like man i got a fart she's not
holding
she's pretty too she goes i got a fart
she goes all right anyways so
she goes i said excuse me what do you
want me to do
we need to change the stigma [ __ ] that
it's funny to me
oh god keep scrolling this is earlier
today it was yesterday keep scrolling
it's going to be a lot
no just go to the second page oh no keep
going
it'd be along here somewhere sure oh
there it is
which one where uh the very top left
what part of the game is
shorty left nope nope right there yeah
is it backwards it just keeps on rolling
man
so she knew she was on camera yeah she's
instagram live [ __ ]
[ __ ] like she had to [ __ ] cute she
said it's hurt my stomach
that's cute hey i get it we've heard
your summer you got to let it out though
you farted because
i said excuse me like you got a problem
fair point
like what are you doing i said excuse me
i [ __ ] love you
it's all right some guy wrote
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah it's so
funny that's a big level
my girl make uh tiger like you know he's
a kid
he farted yeah yeah let's bend over big
ass fart
and my girl makes him say excuse me i'm
like yeah that's so lame
man not me so like i'll fart around him
like dad what do you say i'm like
i say nothing buddy i saved my denial
because i
fart i leave the room yeah yeah i want
to be a [ __ ] tablet
no you don't know you yeah sure just
like
whenever you want to everything gross i
do i mean eventually
yeah around people though no i try not
to yeah
that's another thing you're fighting for
no you're like
straining too hard let's rip the fart
right i mean accidentally
yeah it's so embarrassing but like i've
never like no no i was just
intentionally just like how did you do
did you do your girlfriend in front of
you uh in her sleep
yeah she doesn't know it does she i tell
her
you'd be like wake up girl you'll be
like wake up girl you know
i just started laughing yeah and i fart
on purpose
sometimes to let everybody know yeah let
everybody know what
you do the dutch oven yeah they get
tourists what are you trying to let
people know just that they have to
understand
again like that i get you i'll catch
eyes with you too i'll catch eyes and
lock up
i feel like you do that yep i do that
too sometimes i do this
and i jump
yeah daddy looks like he has some
streaks in those undies
no you know what a little bit though i
got to clean my whistle
i've seen brian clean his wig out of the
day i cleaned my eyes jump up on a
counter sink like a gargoyle and wash
his ass
i cannot i can't have a drink i have to
walk out with you i can't i hate it i'm
gonna jump in the sink and
splash what up your ass no but i have a
good day and i have a
i'd take wipes on my ass has to be as
clean as my hands come on now
at all times i love you what are you
doing on the plane
i'm not talking about that but a lot of
times i won't go until i can get to the
thing i'm not going to put my ass right
he'll go on the plane in a heartbeat
oh no no no oh dude this last time we're
coming back i got these new vitamins and
they have uh digestive enzymes
yeah then they fed me this chicken pesto
this dude
next to me was just you know whole
office set up just
coffee and i went dude dude and he's
like what are you you gotta yeah i'm
sorry you gotta get all this
and i gotta go and he's like right now
i'm like i'm dude you
you got you know where the point where
you're like it's gotta be like oh
he goes like this he's like
typing his password lockout
dreams how do you
oh my knees are touching the door oh
[ __ ] man you did the same thing when we
came back from nashville when we had
that hot chicken i've sat next to
like certain basketball players when
you're six nine it's a major issue
i mean how the [ __ ] he's like poor
stefan strove you know he's seven fights
stephanie street was a ufc fighter
retired seven foot heavyweight
and uh we had the same manager so i know
the story and uh
my manager lex is talking to ufc and
they wanted to send them to like
australia to fight
and they go he's time to take the fight
anyway you could just do best in class
for him because he's seven foot tall
and it's miserable for him to fly he
literally his knees go numb is there
anything you're doing you see goes
no we can't we're sorry he had to fly
how far to australia
ooh no dude they went oh we're sorry
buddy that man he's some foot tall great
nice guy in the world huge yeah he's
such a nice guy
i remember when i met him and brendan
was fighting still
uh-huh i was supposed to fight who's
that right there
and brennan brennan goes brendan
[ __ ] you he's a legend dog
but back then when brennan was with her
around the guy he was mad have to fight
i was like
[ __ ] that was a pibble he'd say [ __ ]
that guy so i'd go like this i'd go
how would you fight that guy and he'd go
you rarely see he goes
he goes oh i'm gonna knock him out
that's how i'm going to fight him i'm
going to knock him out
like out of my i was like oh jesus yeah
you have a bad thing to talk about rats
that's tough you guys like we get three
[ __ ] pitbulls in the same room man
yeah especially when we're also with
each other like we have promotions we
had
we big country um the [ __ ] come on roy
nelson roy nelson
with our boy uh frank mayer yeah in
vegas at the time
very interesting because those two were
very there there was some caution in the
room
they're like i know you know with me and
roy no no not you you're always good
yeah especially then like i'm out of the
game i don't give a
[ __ ] frank mir frank mirror might be the
most dangerous man in the world
we had seven knives on that though and
guns don't [ __ ] with frank muir
[ __ ] that dude's two great guys so they
oh great guys who won that fight
uh frank did frank dude they're both
legends they're both amazing
but frank's like like serious legend
always great too
uh ate too much food dude gotta announce
today don't let that
your boy your boy's going to miami next
week working floyd uh
logan paul really i leave thursday from
miami is that right
you stoked pretty stoked no way i don't
know what they were how long how when
june june 6th right it's the first
sunday
it's fights on a sunday so wayne's
because it's a
entertainment fight exhibition fight so
they don't have to do the mandatory sat
day before right
so the logan uh floyd wayne's on friday
that's kind of like a celebration
weigh-in
and then there's actual real boxing like
organized like commission boxing
they weigh in to the standard saturday
and then the fights on sunday
i'm very i'll tell you what i'm very
excited about what are two things i'm
one thing i'm worried about is floyd's
hands i don't know how brutal they are
so i don't know how hard he's gonna be
hitting uh mr logan paul
but what i'm very interested in i'm
interested to know if if floyd is going
to make
logan pay for the sins of his brother
his brother's taking his hat i wonder
yeah i want to know
and the other thing i want to know is if
i want to see if logan paul can actually
put a glove on floyd mayweather now keep
you in mind he's 44 and i would remind
you that
a guy named manny pacquiao didn't touch
him that's what i was saying he made him
miss
he made canelo miss he's made everybody
miss my only caveat to that you're
assuming
the floyd mayweather is in the same
mental space that he was in
when he fought man yeah
i don't think he's been the same mental
space as when he fought conor i think
he's even looking at this as more as
more more of like i want to punish this
joke no oh more of a joke yeah
really connor's connor's a much better
boxer by far but he didn't even
entertain that really like
i know from closed sources he really
didn't train for that bubba i bet he
didn't did he
no no i'm sure he didn't you didn't
train for conor no
you're talking a different language it's
like if you speak fluent spanish
and i learned it for two weeks and tried
talking to you like dude come on
there's no different like there's no
there's no air it's not even the same
yeah yeah yeah yeah but
i love where logan paul's at on it
because he was on first take and
you know max is on uh uh stephen a smith
is on there
and he's sometimes human smith drives me
nuts but whatever but he goes hey look
he goes low you got to realize like
these real
boxing aficionados and like people like
legend of space
you know they're a little upset that
you're getting this opportunity to fight
floyd like you haven't done anything to
deserve it he goes
i never said i did yeah he he was but
who wouldn't take this opportunity
because also you guys are forgetting
floyd hit me up i wasn't chasing floyd
he hit me up because he knows how much
money he can make find a guy like me
he's like so you know for me it's a
win-win he goes if i lose yeah
everyone's killing me lose
he goes but if i win he's what happens
what happens to the body
by the way i mean you can say whatever
you want about the the paul brothers
they get in the ring they do they do
training work their ass i mean
you know they're both athletic kids and
jake um uh what's this jake's with
showtime now
jake's with showtime he's he's trying to
be a real boxer
yeah that takes balls i don't care what
anybody says like and oh by the way he
makes
how much money is he making crazy amount
crazy so so
what i from what i've seen he's actually
getting in there and boxing with the
real dudes and getting taken he's tuned
up yeah but then taking some
show time then is he gonna get like yeah
legit you're not gonna see lamar odom or
some [ __ ] in there
they're gonna like but he might get like
a mike perry
or you know they're not going to toss
some of the [ __ ] wolves yeah yeah
obviously you're sure as [ __ ] not
getting
you know these youtubers like it's
showtime yeah like showtime they don't
play that game
showtime wanted like a regular
production like
that you know they want tomorrow and you
know they're they're old-school
old heads and don't you think and i told
them i said that's not the way to do
this right he's a big boy what is he
who heavyweight who uh jake 185 what
yeah
yeah he'll be four weight classes
heavier than floyd don't you think don't
know that matter
no no but don't you think it's smart for
him to
fight see what they do don't you think
it's smart for him to fight
mma guys who are like like guys like
mike perry
and and and yeah because because boxing
is different it's just different
distance right
mid distance but he's eventually gonna
have to face a real body yeah but
everyone complaining this that's not the
the path right now yeah like mike perry
would be great there's
some other guys that could i i think
what about um
the guy who always amazes me at his
striking is uh i'd love to see nate diaz
get to be honest i think nate's got so
much more experience nate
boxes all of them have way more
experience yeah but no i mean nate
boxes boxes with boxers and has been
doing that mid-distancing forever
for sure but my thing is is he going to
beat nate no
but i just think that level if you want
to really see where you're at
oh yeah you know that pressure and then
nate this is what i want for nate you'd
make so much money a lot of money
so i want guys to have the opportunity
to make so much money and have that
platform nick or nate diaz would be
great
it's amazing though i'm excited miami
never mind to go to miami
i've been to florida way too many times
way too many times but miami's got
something to say
it's got something to say yeah i'm more
big booties everywhere i'm more of a
naples guy
yeah i'm more of a naples guy you are
for a weekend
i don't know that for a living i can't
live
it's living definitely yeah i can't look
at this in miami the music constantly
everywhere you are
it's a hustle you're [ __ ] and don't
go with jay's shot because he wants to
go down [ __ ] south beach and do the
massachusetts four in the morning
with no problem doesn't need a lot of
sleep either gets up
and he does his damn thing he doesn't
move a lot
jay's not a big he's not a kinetic hyper
guy but jay moves
yeah he moves at his own pace i tell you
what miami is probably my favorite city
in
florida as well it should be it makes
sense i loved it yeah
i mean i don't need to do it like south
beach was a bad guy but he's aggressive
but
yeah i believe i believe i've said this
many times
the best looking people per capita for
me
probably even the guys they're they're
great looking
the beard dominican like is that when
we're here
it's the show's down there cat that was
your first time miami yeah that was my
first time in miami it was beautiful i
think
the day we went because it was i think
the week after the spring break and
there were
the curfew oh the week up yeah we had
that weird curfew so it was a little odd
but
really people are right beautiful people
yeah everywhere you go to the mall and
it's like
everyone has a fat ass everyone their
grandpa had a fat ass
i know yeah i love it they're [ __ ]
nuts we wrote jet skis
might ask me i asked ooh i come up with
things to do i'll take that james
thanks brother yeah right yeah give him
give him that ah
ham hand smother
[ __ ] dude my hands are heavy as [ __ ]
what do you do for a workout do you just
play tether
i lift weights what i lift weights i
play tennis and i'm getting back into
boxing
i'm not gonna spar anymore because well
it's just you don't need a spark you're
good to do it your age
well i told you you know i was getting
dizzy and getting hit you can't do that
you know and i don't get caught in the
jaw sometimes and i'd be like i can't
chew for it
play tennis with jeff yeah yeah jeffy's
getting moved to santa barbara
he's got a house there yeah he's just
staying down jeff
runs on a country road he's the one he
wants he's the best dude
jeff foley just fully one of the best
are you
are you gone doing your uh [ __ ] cut
my life into pieces
you're in phoenix rocking it out what do
you mean boys from h2o
not wife jesus christ take it easy
jeffrey dahmer no uh he's doing a uh
straight up uh punk rock he's jumping on
tour bus doing a punk rock concert i'm
going with the band and i'm doing a song
i know h2o yeah i've heard my boy toby
morris i think he's met you
yeah yeah i think he was frank
gorilla no they were fans of the show
because he sent some stuff to us before
did he that's my boy he we got we got
matching tags oh i know i know i know
him
yeah yeah he's a great guy yeah that's
what's my age
yes no no he's 51. all right well yeah
he's similar though yeah he's good
people though he's 51 rocking out to the
[ __ ]
yeah bro he's tatted up he's he dude
he's
dope dope dude he's friends with john
joseph he's friends yeah yeah i saw
frank grillo today
you got to do that to a person let them
have their own i saw him you know go
down rodeo
probably i don't know it was like i came
downstairs today
my mother i just woke up my mother on
zoom has
the people i grew up with and they're
they now live in india so she's zooming
with
you know and and she's like say hi you
know the first thing
i'm like ah man yeah i love them yeah
but but [ __ ] you know
not right now sometimes you're down to
somebody like uh
like years and then what do you do when
they go since my wedding hey
what are you doing leo what have you
been up to man
do you cover last year oh yeah
my friend has stage four cancer and i go
how are you doing
let me rephrase that let me freeze
phrase that you're doing terrible
terrible how are you managing how are
you yeah
what do you think what happens when
people have told me like what happens
when people when you get sick when
you're going to die
is everybody avoid you because they
don't know what to do that makes sense
so they kind of go
well so but your last three months gets
real quiet
let's take a little break from the
program because i'm here to talk to you
about blue now
what do you need man you trying to get
your mans or your girl
some dope ass jewelry what do you need
you need a diamond
ring cocktail rings gemstone necklace
whatever you need
we got you covered whether you're
customizing an engagement ring or
designing a diamond stud errand for your
man
at bluenow.com you're in control we got
you covered man
ready to pop the question we got you
baby build engagement ring of her or his
dreams at bluenow.com choose from more
than 100 000 ethically sourced
gia graded diamonds every shape and size
with endless selection of settings to
help you design the ring earrings
pendant of her or his dreams daddy
get it done they also have uh experts on
hand 24
7 available phone or chat whatever you
need all right we got you covered man
we got you covered bluenile.com
that's blue nile also if you're not
happy
cool man no problemo 100 satisfaction
guaranteed
shop stress free with guaranteed free
shipping and returns all right
need your special purchase fast you
maybe you're maybe you're you know
you're a little bit lazy or a
procrastinator we got you covered in
most cases blue now can deliver
overnight baby overnight what
every order is insured arising discreet
little package so nobody knows what
you're doing man
make the moment sparkle with the jewelry
from bluenow.com
and the fire and the kids listeners get
50 off 500
this is a podcast exclusive uh includes
engagement rings all right
use fighter that's coach fighter plus
every order is insured ship's free
arrive discreet little package
shop stress free and find your forever
piece go to bluenow.com today
you ever heard of grubhub huh you're
part of the club the grub club
get deals on food you love with grubhub
perks all right
they have a variety grubhub has all the
food you love from your favorite local
restaurants all right
we got you covered man take a break from
cooking maybe you got your friends and
family over for the big fire the big
game whatever it is maybe you want to
try something new and with grubhub all
the local restaurants in your area
you can try a variety of dishes right
pick up order head pick up your favorite
food from your favorite restaurants on
grubhub
all right you're going to love the perks
from grubhub grub what you love
i forgot you're a drummer yeah good
drugs i heard about it
no like one of the best really the best
ever dude
oh i thought i took lessons for a year
and then waste time
i told you my dad played the the oh boom
boom boom
oh yeah my dad dad what are they called
bongos
why did i get the bunga the mangoes the
mangoes i didn't get the
the [ __ ]
here's a skateboard get good on this get
good on doing these he was like he's
actually pretty funny yeah let's go i'll
see you later man
was he taking lessons at all just had it
he's taking mine
dude like don't do the piano ring
scales over there you're doing your
scales you're gonna make it in time
no joke my dad my dad plays the guitar
but he's really good no he's
he's got fingers that are much bigger
than his uh-huh giant hands
and he's got no musical ability none
and i said to him i go listen it's
awesome that you're
older now and you're studying italian
and golf channel you have to quit that
you're trying to keep that
one yeah it stimulates part of your
brain you're so bad
that you shouldn't do it yeah
good luck with that i tried that for a
year [ __ ] good luck with the
piano i tried that you can i got to a
point where i was playing with you
it's like you're playing yeah no i
worked at it hard i worked at it for a
year hard
but you could learn it you can learn
about it but it's technically uh
i know how to play like you're a musical
dude yeah chin can you play piano
yeah i bet i do it by ear huh yeah i
know i was like
i do buy here what do you have sleeve on
tendonitis or tennis elbow is that one
of those iron things like you can see at
late nights
exactly are you sick you're you're
tending nice flaring up get this cool
i looked up online at youtube like what
because there's a weird sensation it
feels like crap in it
i guess it's not helping is it from
sawing bones at night
bones anymore is that helping uh i've
only had for like one day so i'm not
sure i'm going to do it for like a week
and i bought another one for this arm
yeah we're both cool your elbows are
already dude everything in my body is
hurting
it might be arthritis speaking of my
acupuncture how would you guys want to
see something really crazy yeah
take your shirt take my shirt off try
cutting out [ __ ] shades because that's
what i do
i don't even know if i eat it eye shades
excuse me excuse me wait what did you
say
oh you don't know about my i do i do
please don't
i know i didn't tell you about that no
you did please don't no i didn't please
don't do it do it cut out nightshades
i'll look up nicest i don't think i have
any inflammatory response
i thought i was i thought i had full
body arthritis which i did i stopped
doing that a week later remember
your skin got all flavored what was that
psoriasis yeah so i had psoriatic
right daddy had psoriasis
it was bad you take pictures all over my
body how did you get rid of it
uh i got through your stress i got rid
of the stress
oh got it but also also daddy's leg
looked like freddie cruz but also dude i
called i called my
shows freddy krueger's face when i was
in colorado i called my ex i go i think
i have to go to the doctor because i
can't walk well
and then by accident a doctor said do
you have any allergies i said eggplant
they said do you have stiffness in your
joints i go um well my secret is i
i thought i was gonna i was dying i
didn't tell anybody it took me an hour
of yoga just to get moving i never told
anybody
because you don't you know you get
nervous yeah so [ __ ] cut that [ __ ]
out i swear to god a week later
you know i was like i was doing jiu
jitsu how many eggplants were eating at
night
wait so when i would eat eggplant i
wouldn't understand my throat would
close up and i get it i get a pain
i if you touch this part of my head just
this part
this is nice bro you'll be like oh
eggplant just like a little tab
parmesan see ya i don't like your
attitude about my allergy dudes in
people's diets
you know what you need to do bro dude
i'm a doctor
it's 44. i don't think i even need to
stop doing this yeah but you shouldn't
yeah i don't think that you know what
you know what if
anything's inflammation he's exercising
no he no he needs to [ __ ] work hard
what is it
the inflammation is from korean bbq no
alcohol most likely
i drink every day i know i can't cut
that out baby limit it okay so what
happened with your
tiger's droppings soon how about you
drinking how much you're drinking a
blood drink
no not about that get real a couple
drinks a couple drinks yeah i'll have
like
truly's i have like two or three truly
and maybe a glass of wine what are true
the uh seltzer yeah beer they're really
good the lemonade ones they're really
good
but uh so i did the catch you drink no
very early she never drinks she drink
with me once on my birthday oh she's
drinking naps i feel like
oh my god in nashville jelly rolls
yes and it was good from the club you
know jelly roll he's like
three four hundred pounds lucy said
his name's jelly roll lucy because he he
had like alcohol skim tone
we said it looked like the solar system
like jelly roll is the sun we're all
just
yeah yeah yeah cause we're all just just
in rotation it was so much fun
goes man great stories great voice man
have you seen the newest video he posted
on his instagram he's back on twitter oh
yeah
hundreds of thousands of people singing
a song word for word like jelly roll's
blowing the [ __ ] up man there's
something else
who's this guy it's uh that's right on
the right of the crowd
right there wow yeah look it's all about
this recent
come on that's amazing
how nuts is that crazy this is first
show better the nicest guy too yeah
sweetheart jelly roll that's my guy
save me oh he'll take care of you when
you when you're out there in nashville
he goes bubba anything you need yeah
he's all great dude
you have a prom you call me if someone
steals your rolex i'll get it back i
told him
you should just sit around and have
story time next to a fire yeah tell
[ __ ] stories man
so that's his daughter and that's his
dime piece wife wow
wow great dude he's the best yeah that's
the best
love that guy he's good people one of my
favorite people i'd love to be able to
sing were you about to bring up chin
before we went to oh my
god oh let's take your shirt off i'll
take you posted a picture of the day
you're like how jacked am i
my back is kind of random yeah let me
see i don't know why
i'm so pale i'm so pale that's why
you're not paler than me
first of all dude you're more tan than
christian and brunch you look at my
thing
you look at my body you go snow blind
baby you go snow blind
he's like an irish tan oh even though
you're italian
oh you got cups whoa some cupping what
does that do
that sucks up that's like a plateau it
releases the toxins from your body yeah
it's how does it bring the blood
to the area has it been working
i hope so that's my third time i went we
were in that jeremy lin
sleeve i don't that's for the back
that's not for the elbow yeah
yeah that's why i'm praying i'm praying
to worse i'm praying for you
and you you used to be 300 pounds or
something great right 285 he was just
doing 500 300.
what do you weigh now 180.
i'm too light i should definitely be at
least keep that 180. no i gotta be too
[ __ ] wait
you're working what do you think bryan
no push-ups that's it yeah
oh there you go i think he's [ __ ]
lifting and pushing his the keyboard
go go go meet them at their gym no i'm
to take your advice you have that guy
right yeah
30 minutes 20 minutes 20 minutes yeah
what is it that's me some guy but it's
like 60 bucks an hour that's
all right six months a session it's so
worth it
that's something no no no it's worth
personal training that's too hot all
right tell you what just come do it i'll
buy you the first
three and you tell me all right what you
think or you can come
hang out with mark and uh i'm not too
i'm not two something though
i always i'll get to tucson you guys are
going heavy you're you're you're going
hello it's not no don't come there no no
it's not
don't go
so david luke
david lucas you know opens up for me on
the road savage [ __ ] roast master
he goes out he goes dude i love this i
can't believe
he goes dude my boy is like super
connected in houston man he's going to
take care of us
and he walks out the door i look at
chicago but i don't do
like after shows i just want to go back
to airbnb take my [ __ ] shoes off and
watch tv and rest
yeah and drink water and yeah hookah or
just hang out with you guys yeah i'm not
trying to go to the club
and we're all like no no this wants to
go i'm like we got to tell david
something so we walk out there
awkward
the guy he's like you know he's like a
ladies man he's like
oh my are you telling this he's like
he's dead and there's
three chicks one one you know lizzo
figure
girl the big girl yeah and then two
normal ones and he's talking he's like
yeah we're going this is some fancy club
in houston
he goes you you two can get in i can't
get your big ass in
and i'm i hear y'all he's straight up
girl bro
what that's just cool because i can't
get her in that ain't happening
sweetheart i ain't getting a big ass
saying i was like
hey man he said we talked to him he said
he can't do it he said he said
a therapy and jim sessions could help
you out
i don't like that guy oh so so one was
awkward
so i don't like that so no no one does
so they will they would walk off and
like the girls were laughing on her and
i'm like what the so
i'm like we're good man and we get in
our cars they had like a escalade or
something first like
we're good we had a driver that used
driver so we go back to airbnb
the next day one of those girls i
realized works at the club
and i went and found and said hey i want
you to i don't know that guy that guy
talked to your friend like that he's not
with us
you talk to your big fat friend like
that that ain't cool
no
no i said that's ain't going to cut it
sweetheart do you want to talk to your
big fat friend
that ain't going to cut it right don't
let that right not roll don't roll this
where's it
from apparently
i stopped being friends with a guy who
said he said this girl's a for
a ditcher she was a friend of mine and
the girl was cool the girl was what what
was she a phone to her face i looked at
her
he said to her face yeah and i said or
like like no
no he said and i said to him say who it
was
which one am i not are you reminded
oh yeah do i know the person but of
course i do and i said i said to him i
go i go dude in the you're the guy in
the movie i [ __ ] punched in the face
right now oh
uh i never forgot him but he's
hey dude you're the guy i punched in the
face in the in the movie i punch you in
the face and i keep punching in the face
too
you're uh i i was young and i you know i
used to lose my [ __ ] mind over stuff
like that i hate
that show yeah don't hurt people's
feelings man it's well it makes me
[ __ ] i don't like a bully and i never
you only didn't get me to fight itself
that's why i said hey
your big fat friend don't worry about it
hey bro i brenden that's your best you
know
brendan you are fat shaming no not at
all no but she she was like no she
we laughed it off like i said joke i was
like he is a joke you don't have to
worry about he's a pimp
yeah it sucks though yeah he's
literally a pimp i was just like hey
how's everyone doing like i didn't know
what you know me like hey everyone
i hear you two are cool but you're not
getting in nothing
i went oh what
you gonna do some therapy in a workout
session i was like whoa
dude yeah it's 20 21. we can't talk like
that
when i was in greece as a young man and
my daughter my sister was probably 18 or
19
and this girl who was this really hot
girl said call my sister a pig
in uh italian or french and my
friend told us what she said and then
the girl said you are pig you're a pig
you know because my my sister was not
all dog
she was american that hurt my feelings
well your sister looks like you with a
wig
my sister like no she was
my sister went my sister went she just
goes
boom and just [ __ ] hip jack bumper
ass bumped her like that and the girl
came back and she went
boom and asked but your sisters are
tough they got a fight
with a tough girl yeah she was like i
would say your sister's toughen you
your son is a tough girl yeah holds a
grudge yeah and goes
go and we'll get you back yeah because
she'll be like brendan and you're like
okay yeah yeah she'll get back yeah
she'll be like brandon you should whip
up up
and you're like oh damn yes yes yes yes
yes older younger younger
younger sister protective over me yeah
oh hello yeah
that's good she's a rock yeah not not
sentimental
not sentimental oh you got a full
suffering people like
the cows are a little dead behind the
eyes a little bit oh really
well not the most effective mom my mom
is but my pops
my sister and the other italian side the
sicilians
they they got some they they just
also had people also his sister lives in
the biggest house you've ever seen
oh really oh you get lost in the
backyard it's jumanji back there yeah
yeah
it's crazy yeah they gotta meet her it's
a nice house i've ever seen
40. handsome devil yeah you retired at
40. yeah one of my favorite people
smart even my girl goes man he's
handsome like he's like a guy
oh he's a [ __ ] alpha he's a god real
is he swedish or german swedish
sweetheart
he's swedish from sweden yeah he's
sweden and he loves soccer
soccer yeah yeah he's made his has the
accent and everything yeah
and and just and you know um you never
see a miami fan like he's
he's a he's a real fan of certain sports
and gets pissed when they lose just a
guy
like my sister's oil rolling he wouldn't
talk to his competitors
like his competitors when when he was
banker like w guys
and his team would be over there
championship and he'd be like i don't
talk to those guys
i hate him yeah he's a beast he's one of
those competitive [ __ ] damn
yeah
the house is stupid he's got a bing
it's my joke it's like you walk in and
you go money does kind of buy happiness
it's like those houses if you've seen
those houses in dubai that they're now
dropping into the water have you seen
those with the underground
bring those up for a second you've seen
those yeah but you're in dubai though
you know
you're in dubai but if you do do buy
right if you got the money you got
everything to buy
everything if you have a private jet
engine or chopper well you got it well
there you go
well that's what you got that's your
house oh yeah i feel comfortable no
underwater i would never do that yeah i
would never you wouldn't
no just get a place in miami oh man that
looks pretty [ __ ] cool
i mean it looks cool it looks terrible i
i wouldn't mind spending like two days
there i don't trust them
where there's no leaves that's what they
say and then the first
[ __ ] damn tsunami will come through
dude i'm living in there and i'm diving
in the water just get a yacht
how do you get water to your to your i
don't know you better get grocery shop
early huh look at that there
you have a coral reef so you're down
there looking at animals no
i'm not that interested no really i
would not
i couldn't do it i don't feel
comfortable that gives me anxiety it's a
vacation house
you know yeah like i'm saying even
though it's homes off malibu that are
still yeah yeah give me such anxiety did
you see a party
the other day no 50 people i've always
thought of this
50 people [ __ ] yay [ __ ]
this like last week in malibu malibu
party
uh [ __ ] crashes now that [ __ ] that'll
happen on stairwells
how could it not dude stilts there's
these stilts on the side of the frame
in sand in wet sand when frank grillo
went to this frank grillo
went to shoot [ __ ] uh oh let's see
this so there it is crash but there's
actual video of them
eating [ __ ] yeah malibu everybody
we're [ __ ] doing it check out the
sunset hard pass
frank frank was doing in senegal he was
doing uh that
show and get ready for this this is
this one i don't hang on malibu anymore
there were too many people on that
little patio space still though
you got it nothing just could happen
where they stand to the right she gave
us the god damn so nobody was killed but
it's a lot
oh no they died no
in a second a dream of a day on the
golden coast of malaysia that's not
crazy i bet remember where you say hang
out pivots really bad we have pivots
i was all up on there my shirt off and
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's not a lot of that's not
fun
chilling it's uh we're just chilling bro
uh
necklaces papa yeah now what are the
lawsuits gonna look like
who gets sued besides everybody i don't
know there's a city whoever built
whoever built it yeah nope because i
would assume when you have homework
insurance you have home insurance but
also we buy that property i guarantee
you that's worked into the
contract well the inspector who it all
depends
nine injuries four people transferred
local hospitals no questions
oh no
you guys were into it though yeah it was
you know what i almost did you know what
the problem is they're big fat fans what
you know my story about my sister hip
checking yeah i almost told that story i
was like i don't like that part of the
story i should say
i should say she was going i got it and
i was like i don't know how to do that
pig thing and it won't work so i had to
tell them
better if you owned them yeah and that's
a better score and then bitter tip
and
yeah yeah no but i didn't do that
all right sometimes you want to just add
a little so you everyone's been in the
middle of a story and you go i don't
have an ending this is terrible i got to
come up with something that's how i was
watching
he lied about death i didn't lie i
thought nine people died
we get we sometimes we tell stories and
we'll lie yeah and then
you know that we lied and then it's for
you but then i tell you friend goes that
didn't happen huh the shark didn't put
you in the mouth and spit you out yeah
and i go but i heard about it and then
you realize that you don't even know
where you heard that
and then it's your story and that's your
story it's your story there are three
sides to every story right
your side my side and the truth and
nobody's lying
yep memories
hey you don't judge my journal i'm not
i'm saying write it down dog this is
good
why that tone you know who said that
robert evans the great producer right
junior also said it
iron man you know i'm the president of
the thick boy bike club but i didn't
start on the trails i started on the
peloton that's right i started with
world-class instructors curated music
endless fitness variety peloton has
created on matt's fitness experience to
keep you
motivated workout after workout i love
the trainers on there
that was my favorite favorite thing
about peloton your boy still rides it
from time to time
when i'm not on the real trails all
right their instructors are the best
they're so much fun
you got dope music hip-hop country you
can pick your music
you can pick your genre whatever you
want cardio and strength you can get on
the bike they have weight assisted they
have all this stuff for you to get
in freaking healthy healthy shape man
get started on your peloton journey
right now go to onepeleton.com to learn
more
that's o n e p e l o t
o n dot com peloton man
get your journey started right now from
some of the best workout equipment in
the world it's peloton baby
so you might be sitting back and just
start your own online store maybe it's
thick boy merch makes your own merch
whatever it is you're doing what you
love selling products the people want
there's the demand and the order's
coming fast
i got you covered man now the hard part
shipping those products
that's a beast luckily ship station
makes it easy with ship stations number
one
simple to import manage and ship your
orders out fast for a lot less money
it's no wonder shipstation is the number
one
shipping software for e-commerce sellers
with more than five-star reviews than
anyone else import orders from any sales
channel ship with any carry using their
deeply discounted rates automate just
about any shipping task
spend a lot less time shipping and a lot
more time growing your
business all right and you can do it in
way less time than any other place
all right shipping more ship a lot more
in less time
just use the code fighter to get 60 day
free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress free shipping
listen when finally kid first started i
was doing my own merch i was using ship
station it was so freaking easy and it
saved us a lot of money and got the
teas and the merch out to you guys fast
i love ship station just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone atop the home
page type in fighter
that shipstation.com enter the code
fighter make ship happen
already what do you got first one so a
39 year old drug dealer over in
liverpool was found out based off of a
photo of him holding
a block a of cheese no
so apparently he sent this photo onto
a uh app called encrow chat which
basically
is used for nefarious reasons drug
dealing money laundering stuff like that
the gov the english government actually
got a hold of it and started going
through
all of these chats and trying to
identify who it was they matched
his fingerprints from this photo to the
actual man who was behind the chat
that's not surprising to me at all a
little bit though right they now have a
laser
that can shoot into your that records
the beat of your heart because please
understand that your heart
beats very uniquely just like your
fingerprints no your heart just beats
it has its own beat so they they they
can literally
somehow the laser measures your heart
rhythm your beats
and they know exactly another way to
track your data so your heart has a
signature
cool and facial recognition is the real
thing facial recognition they use a lot
in china right
they they use it here they use it here
now they use it when you do clear so
they can find out
what do you think the government does
when you do clear when i scans my face
i'm like yeah that makes sense the
privacy is gone you're you're being
tracked all the time
you're always being tracked but this guy
was arrested and he got 13 years and six
months
in prison currently 60 000 people use
that chat
and now the government is going through
it
[Music]
they must really be they're cracking
down 13 years you know it's been doing
some [ __ ] yeah
that's a lot of drugs technology's crazy
yeah
that's what it is okay so
oh my god who saw john cena trying to
speak chinese
no no he's good he's good he's good yeah
he knows how to speak mandarin
well no he was probably given the
phonetics so what happens is they give
you the phonetics no he's done it before
no he's done it i've seen him over there
he actually learned some of the language
yeah but his apology is so cringy
the problem is that he's apologizing to
china for suggesting that taiwan's a
country
yeah and i think that's that's that's uh
i i don't agree with that no
nobody's worse than lebron james though
so during me and jay were talking about
this like if
if like for john cena he's not out there
crying about you know systematic racism
and all this stuff
and equal rights and then is endorsing
china and because he wants his movie to
do well like john cena they're like
bro what you did you're you're probably
out 30 million dollars
bro i would learn chinese real fast real
fast the pressure is enormous but i just
i'm sorry this is where you play this
place i find it hilarious i mean
it's just chinese though yeah it's great
he's good it's the biggest lips in the
world
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry this is the type of white man my
parents would have wanted me to bring
home
someone who knew the language better you
better learn [ __ ] you better tell steve
you learn some [ __ ]
[Music]
vietnamese
absolutely not i do you i know you speak
certain languages
correct i speak candies oh cat you'd
love this last night me and tiger were
swimming yeah
we joke around i'll go i'll go hey look
over there you know there's a [ __ ]
lion and yeah oh then he'll look and i
jump and swim across he tries to catch
me
and then he goes look your friend's over
there i go and i wouldn't look i go
which friend i'm not looking at it's cat
cat's over there oh
but you know he he to refer to china as
it's like when the
who guy like wouldn't talk about taiwan
or even except that it exists
and it's like i that that pressure is so
real
and if you're going to be if you're
going to speak for
social justice then then you can't
choose you're defending china yeah you
know so okay
so what about that's why nobody takes
lebron serious that's also why the
ratings are
in the [ __ ] they are oh dudes down 30
40
right for basketball that's huge no
that's huge look it up 30 40
i watched it yesterday because the sun's
right wait so he got his loss for
speaking in chinese
no no so he was doing a promotional
campaign for the new fast and furious
movie and
during one of the press junkies he
referred to taiwan as a country and
there's a lot of beef between china and
taiwan taiwan
trying to be its own country and china
not recognizing it and recognizing it as
a part of china
so when he said that he pissed off the
chinese people and the chinese
government he then went on to apologize
to them
considers taiwan part of china and after
shanghai uh sort of escaped fought
fought you know fought against the
chinese essentially the communist
government
and moved and brought his forces over to
taiwan they founded taiwan and so it's
all very connected
i apologize i lied i said 40 percent
down it's 48
down i'm sorry what
oh how woke do you want to be nba whoa
and and did you see what happened to the
the he was a general manager for the
houston
uh rockets he said something about
how like we shouldn't [ __ ] with china
he's like
i mean you want to human rights what
about china hong kong
lebron goes this guy needs to get out of
the league all these players are like he
needs to get out of there he needs to
get out of there
and you know what china you know what
china did they blacked out all the nba
games went oh you're gonna allow that
guy to do that he got fired they're
gonna allow him to do this we're not
gonna hear you so china has this
hijacked i'd be like oh
[ __ ] you man you can't do this so this
is where you decide who you are
so how much money do you need well so so
at the end of the day just as long as
you realize
that that you're you're a dollar bill
and you do have a price
you're a [ __ ] you know what the price
is four billion dollars
i believe what they get from it's very
real four billion but unless you stand
up to them and say [ __ ] four billion
dollars then
so you so what you're saying is that you
your decision to do right or wrong
is buyable i can buy your morality
i can buy your ethics and i can buy
human life so don't ever play so what
you're doing is you're placing
a dollar bill on human lives on human
suffering
on the uyghurs but more importantly on
freedom of speech and all the things
that we enjoy
but you are saying it's okay for the
communist government of china
to do that to its own see if he lost his
job that's cool so don't ever don't ever
don't ever speak about morality it'll
pop up you've gotten so much [ __ ] you
lose all your credibility
this is what got him started to
firestorm
he had to apologize did he get fired
uh i thought he did so opposed to tweet
supporting protesters in hong kong
because
you know because that's the right thing
to do if you like equal rights yeah
uh if you like democracy if you like i
don't want nba china want them to
sack you uh general manager but they did
it
it's it's disgusting it's disgusting
that americans and an american industry
is caving in china over this
it's [ __ ] disgusting scary how much
it makes once
yeah and and so you're not you're
un-american and you're [ __ ] more
importantly you're just
anti-human jesus christ
makes me crazy
keep his job he was not fired he spent
it he was he was not
or forced apologizing good god bless the
nba does what i mean good
but you just look at the way the nba is
moving and it's like no one's watching
it he said he put that down though
oh yeah he did step down he was giving
up he was given he was given
a face-saving choice so he did he didn't
lose his job
well he already stopped yeah oh god
that's not his fault that's the [ __ ]
that's the nba oh did you see uh you
know kenny
kenny maine for espn you know he they
fired him
no kenny mayne fired him his last
interview he did was with aaron rodgers
it's his very last interview this is it
and he goes
he's talking aaron uh rogers they're
friends though so that's why it's funny
but if you didn't know it you'd be like
holy [ __ ]
and he goes dude you told me he goes i'm
gonna end it with this you told me
invest in bitcoin it's down whatever
forty percent
and you also told me something else he
goes uh and i lost my job so [ __ ] you
aaron rodgers and walks off
on air live on here [ __ ] you air and
roger yeah with my situation look
it's it's never been about uh you know
never been about the draft pick picking
jordan i love jordan he's a great kid
ah man hold on
last thing last time we did the
interview together you told me to go
heavy in the crypto currency game
i did uh we're down 40 percent then i
lost my job gretchen just wants a new
comforter
cue aaron rodgers
with their homies yeah watch out he was
i love you kenny i love you ken
he just tripped us down forty percent
why did he
lose his job yeah so he didn't lose his
job he left because
the the new contract his contract was
over they were not giving him enough
money
so oh but they've like go a lot of the
big boys at espn
just a new regime this china [ __ ] drives
me crazy man
it makes me [ __ ] nice move to china
dude fight your fight i didn't like it
when i was there yeah i moved to china
then
man yeah just don't don't talk to me
about any kind of don't
make a moral stand on anything [ __ ] you
get a honk tattoo you [ __ ]
you won't get a phone [ __ ] bang for a
dollar bill [ __ ] get a [ __ ] hong kong
you won't get a hong kong
[ __ ] yeah i won't get a hong kong tattoo
that's actually something i would do
yeah you're not though i will
you definitely weren't you supposed to
get a fighter in the kids tattoo many
times i'll get that too
no he wasn't he was supposed to years
ago once we got to 10 million downloads
you supposed to do it and
but i will be lazy
though yeah that's the problem is it
yeah you don't need to get attacked it's
just a little bit like
yeah it's like i don't watch yeah yeah
i'd rather
hey man i don't like the way you speak
about my age anymore
you just can't wait till you start aging
dude
yeah i'm not mad at it why would you be
that's good
got some density going on
here they go you know i'm going to
denver this weekend to grapple you are
you going to get your black
we'll see how long has it been since you
got your you you grappled
uh not that long how long
well sometimes yeah long time yeah
probably right before a little more
no before the pandemic really yeah what
were you doing secretly
i feel like brian doesn't believe you no
you think you still you think you still
got it
i mean i can't do an hour like i used to
do but i'm sure you snap you you snap a
man's head down and darts them up a
little bit
you got a couple moves that are very
hard to stop some old this dog has some
ultrasound see i've seen people try to
stop the old snap down
snap city because you'll snap bang and
all of a sudden it's a big problem for a
lot of people or you get behind them
seat belt them
and just drive their head into their
[ __ ] and that's a big problem for
everyone
i i would imagine you've gotten some
pretty high level guys on that something
like that yeah what else you got chin
yeah
that's something suck so photos of taika
watiti uh tessa thompson and rita ora
are going fire
he is the director of thor ragnarok
and he did jojo rabbit he played hitler
he also directed that movie
so he's in a relationship with rita ora
and recently photos of him rita ora and
tessa thompson who's in the thor movies
went viral
yeah they're all just hanging out having
a good time that's cool relationship
mm-hmm no or that's just a threesome
kind of i think
taika is with rita ora and then tessa
like is the extra that she's the side
yeah so they're throttle
i don't think they're start well i think
uh reed is just having fun with the
couple
yeah you've never heard of a throbbing
never heard of novel and then this
morning she was actually photographed
uh the actress tessa with another really
good looking guy
making out damn they're just having a
great time
man a lot of dick
do your thing good for them both hotties
man
tessa thompson's smoke show oh yeah
smoke show
beautiful zoey kravitz has got something
to say huh she's a cute cute one
uh she's the new catwoman yeah she's a
new catwoman
good for her click on that what else you
got jen
one sec is it hot in here
yeah it is hot heat i like the heat i
started getting all sweaty i don't do
well in the cold
the old black polo yeah the only one
what is what is that uh logo it's a
dragon bone
no that's a gross oh that is huh yeah
that's the brand dragon bro
yeah i don't know oh pretty expensive
brand
yeah who makes that this is my boy daisy
oh daisy may had co he's a g
did you get your dad a hat from there no
dude
ordered a hat and from my guy yeah
it said it was shipped and everything
someone stole it was not at my door
so yeah i'm pretty sad about it we'll
catch them slipping
i know just want to fly us at you you
order a hat for your dad or for yourself
it was for me ian barber i have like
four of them you brought one of mine
and we ain't get the same size head dude
i don't know you guys
you got a head on yeah you got a head on
me but you know what's funny is that
brennan has
he brendan you weigh 230
40 242 keep going but it's funny because
you you
look smaller than him i look smaller
than him yeah your bone structure is not
what his
he's got long arms and 5 11. i know but
yeah
and you're six four but you you look a
little bit bigger than
him and you weigh the same six four no
you look bigger in general yeah wider
yeah
you look wider you look like a much
bigger than [ __ ] well how do i look
you look thick you look great well how
cool he looks
you're thick you thick kid yeah but he
looks he just looks like uh he looks
like a bit of a
like he carries a cudgel who me no you
he's a giant
a real life giant he carries gravy no i
said you look like you carry
a satchel of gravy yeah do i
do i look like i carry that it's not
like i'm not i don't look at you and go
he's been missing meals you know what i
mean
i don't say that but i also say i also
if you're holding a sign
and you know but but but he looks like
different that's gonna get i just gotta
get like this this is a it's all diet
you still eating that vegetarian [ __ ]
all the time
vegan oh you're doing this why are you
doing that why would you do that
yeah high five high carbohydrates i like
vegan food yeah
keep heavy stay you don't know what i'm
eating lentils and [ __ ] all that a lot
of bread and thai and like [ __ ] yeah
i eat pad thai with you a lot of beans
and nuts and bread yeah what do you say
a lot of beans nuts and bread
enjoy that you don't know what i'm
eating you [ __ ] hard huh you just
wait what a lot of greens i'll fight
both of y'all
all right go through him first though i
know yeah i gotta get it's like mortal
kombat
if you gotta get into the [ __ ] if you're
gonna jump the undertaker you gotta take
care of the little guy yeah
that was it paul bear call bear you're
gonna take a
wash my hands you got anything else gin
want some more uh maybe
one more i'm hot all right so there's a
stegosaurus
statue in barcelona
and then a father and a son walked by
smelled something weird found out
someone actually died inside its leg
apparently the guy dropped his phone
inside the stegosaurus leg got stuck
phones on the other side and he just
rotted dude that's a [ __ ] way to die
i'm not buying it hold on it was inside
the museum
yes it's not a museum so it's like
there's a cinema and they just use the
statue to get people to you know look at
the cinema yeah and so
no one can hear the guy going hell no
idea that's the statue right there well
it looks like this i wonder if i saw two
different ones
body of missing was found inside a paper
mache dinosaur that's another weird
thing paper mache
well you might have gotten stuck we know
how you beat paper mache when it gets
all hard he just went like this
you start licking it or you guys spit at
it
you're just like think about it get the
paper all wet bro
damn it if you're like this bubba and
you're upside down
i'm pissing i'm pissed and hard dude can
you be like that i'm pissing hard
although you got to reach for your phone
but you can't reach your phone if you
call 9-1-1
wait you said his phone fell in there
that's what they think they're doing an
investigation but they think
he lost his phone in there so he tried
to get in there
or maybe just a beast that high and go
see or you got
murdered and they stuck in there but
that's possible too i think he got
murdered
how did you climb how did you climb into
the leg i know it doesn't make any sense
there's no real pictures either
that's [ __ ] up but yeah now [ __ ] that
what a terrible way to [ __ ] fight if
you're trying to get his phone like
let that phone die that's what they
think happened though oh
can you imagine man he's upside down
help
dude if i get kind of don't tell my kids
i died in a paper mache
[ __ ] me in a leg
yeah the real dog i'll take almost any
other way to die besides that
i i'll tell you what paper mache yeah
i'm gonna put you i'm gonna stuff you in
that
leg or i'm gonna throw you in the congo
river with a
giant crocodile i'm taking the croc yeah
croc is quick
i'm so scared oh yeah that's that's the
127 hours oh
[ __ ] that the croc just grabs you down
you know how long it's gonna take
yeah you did yeah so i told my girl i
died in a car crash something you tell
my kids the cartel picked me up and i
fought
you know what i did yeah i [ __ ] up
what i put in the world comes at me like
and now it's stuck in its [ __ ] eyes
butterfly wow butterflies away
or underwater quiet you know he's been
you know who's been quiet this entire
episode
yeah with you dude nothing i'm just
enjoying
just watching how's that nose oh it's so
it's getting better someone put their
hands on you yeah
yeah my brother did well he didn't put
his hands down you heard the word on the
street yeah he hit you across the face
with the cookies
yeah so more like yeah the cookie sheet
we got him with a cookie cheese first
people were cooking cookies and you guys
saw are you anyway you know what dude
like home alone nah i was like i was
cooking dinner on uh the cookie sheet
and
him and i were getting each other's
faces why uh just stupid [ __ ] we've been
locked in the house
like we've been in the house together
living together for the past two years
get mad at each other no not really i
mean like kim and i are cool now like
brother
matt yeah yeah brother matt what was the
argument over do you remember um figure
this out
i don't think so you can't even have it
it's always something stupid
i think one of us like knocked over a
drink or something like that
and uh so i my our roommate tried to
like step in between us
and i had the cookie sheet to like use
as a shield while i was throwing punches
and my brother just was like nope ripped
out of my hand
and slammed it over my head like a wwe
man yeah
he was he was the wwe version of martha
stewart basically
um but that hit you right in the nose
did you call your phone
nose i know my parents didn't know for
like three days i ain't i'm not gonna
have a stitch um but to make things
worse so later that day
uh i was going to play kickball like
later on and then my roommate
sorry i'm sorry how old are you whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
no
the rest of the story doesn't matter
does it because now you're 22 going to
kickball
you playing kickball league is that is
that before dodgeball or what where is
uh before dodgeball is it crazy kick the
ball uh yeah
what does that mean we get like 50 20
people to show up let me ask you this
all white guys no we have our neighbors
are black they come it's they
do they pitch pretty diverse yeah
diverse so you play where
kickball look just saying look we just
started doing it during the pandemic do
you kick the face
uh no but i got out of the car to go
back into the house to get it lighter
my roommate didn't realize i was behind
his car puts his car into ver
reverse backed into me and my body like
bounced off the back of his car like i
went
like five ten feet back
when you play as people are running to
base can you beam them with the [ __ ]
ball
oh yes okay how do you do you ever mix
it up try this once you guys get
a couple of your [ __ ] uh white claws
where you guys drink playing kickball
yeah and you do crazy kickballs when we
kick the ball
you can go to third or first that's
crazy kickball is what you're saying
that's cool
you guys are chirping the kickball but
why don't you guys show up i guarantee
you guys will be tired sounds like a
blast christian i would i'm not going to
show you well i
would kickball because i
awkward trying to get in with us real
good and goes dude you want to play
catch i go
i'm with chris i'm with dylan and brian
in the hallways of the comments triangle
what he goes what's that saying just
brandon goes yeah for sure man sometimes
goes yeah for sure you know hit me up i
guess
he was one of those things should play
catch dude throw the rock around
dude i have kids i'll tell you what if
it was 1982 i'd be all over this
yeah okay well it was either this is
early 90s it happened during the
pandemics
dropped me off with high c if it's early
90s well it happened during the
pandemics always either
blow my brains out or go to a random
field and play kickball with a bunch of
people i'm sorry i mean like it's just
got us out of the house
but you guys are still playing yeah like
every once in a while
like a random gaming like you know
10 years ago you and i are playing with
will sasha
i organized the game and i just didn't
got one yeah didn't show up
i've never showed up i just didn't show
up i was there with
nine random friends and i was like uh
nice to meet you guys
i was playing volleyball and i was like
ah i'm just not going to go
i was too far away it was too much of a
household i'm such a beast
oh god it's fun though it was a good
time
we had to do that again yeah i didn't
have any gray hair when we played that's
how long ago was
[ __ ] time flies dude uh-huh that was 10
hours to go by
we got to do that again dude what have
we done that lately ten years now we're
busy now aren't we
i never see you outside this podcast i
know i don't see anybody why i see your
bell
i think that's i think that's a mistake
to not see people
do say less thanks buddy we gotta start
doing more you know what i never got
over
you have regular fingers and giant palms
what a solid observation it's not
proportional it bothers me
no i don't have like huge hands i just
have a real big palm he's got a giant
slap look at this we're slapping he's
got the longest pocket
is that is that the one you broke he's
got he's got he's got uh aquaman palms
yeah
he's going for switch basically he
should have just went no he's got your
ball we got long chapelle's [ __ ]
fingers
i have long fingers these are long man
how are you they're better to play
guitar with my dears
be honest what are you working with down
here you know i've never seen it
i've asked the same question i've never
seen it he gets all uncomfortable with
it
why dude this is an initiation in the
club dude hey you kiss my ass
well we'll see you by the way you're not
working with that why you
why you want to know keep that same
energy when we see you by the europe
because i'm you guys are just [ __ ]
seeing everybody here's a couple of
peeping toms
you've seen everybody yeah we're a
couple people time peeping tom
yeah look at me you're a difficult one
you're here you're safe nobody's
listening
what do you know so if you're naked it
looks like the letter q
what do you what do you looks like a
letter q we got a little uh
yeah i mean how do we do it i don't
think i've ever heard that yeah how do
we do how do we do well
you're okay right yeah i'm fine no
complaints no complaints but you're not
like it's not like mandatory because you
know i feel like you'd have that energy
yeah if i had mandate yeah you might
gotta get out of here
yeah i'm sorry oh this little thing
this this little thing
that's how i am with guys i'm a little
gay i assume yeah you run around naked
too damn much in the airbnb
when i take you out of the shower
i don't care dude yeah i'll be naked all
the time dude you definitely see me
i come out dude him and david lucas i
come out my underwear and like oh my god
put some clothes like
no one been in the locker room before i
got gifts uh no i'll give you a little
peek
i'll i'll slap chappelle's ass before he
gets on stage every time i'm like hey
dog will you stop
and you've been crushing it right that's
football [ __ ]
yeah man slap that out we didn't do that
in cheerleading really
no yeah he did some other stuff though
didn't you what
you know what no he's got no irony and
nuance he's like what
you know what what are we doing
cheerleading yeah what do we do since
you cheered no i didn't cherish i think
i've seen a lot of dogs though
you've seen a lot of dogs yeah i want
someone on netflix
what did it say in the documentary that
we do well in the legal report
jerry oh this [ __ ]
about jerry from netflix he was like on
l under the red carpet
and it comes out he was having sex with
a lot of the underage kids he's in
prison for life now
oh that's not life
you keep calling my boy and i literally
have never met that guy
i'm waiting i'm a hard time
what about your best friends and cheered
and friends with all those organizations
he's never ran by him no no he hasn't
cheered
how long his best friend still coach i
dude i haven't cheered since 2013.
i haven't fought since 2000 [ __ ] 13
but i still know all the guys
but like i'm not like but here's the
thing you do i don't do
a podcast about cheerleading kiss my ass
yeah i don't do a podcast about
truly i don't know like the i mean you
never need to know somebody
your best friend i probably still i'm
probably still a [ __ ] kick ass your
friends balls deep enough you think you
can yeah you think
you get back into gym director i was
watching this one dude
he would flip he'd do something and the
girl would do a handstand holding her up
with one hand and then
go back i'm sorry i got to show you
everything dawg hold on
is that was that you were watching a
video chappelle yeah oh he doesn't play
around no
real [ __ ] you got to be the world
champion no yeah world champion
can we say national champ i feel better
with that yeah no
i'll bring the ring in next time we do
it i'm sure it says world on there but
the thing is
is like i beat out puerto rico in costa
rica
uh who was there no colombia colombia is
a powerhouse
come on now yeah because they have the
resources colombia
what about china and australia and
europe did you beat them
um no they didn't they didn't make it to
finals oh
yeah what do i mean so it was world
championships
was it on espn yes bro i used to love
them
i took it off on no one's watching
bruh yeah y'all better believe in me
that's all i know i know i do
i've seen your skills no this video is
taking forever
but keep talking no no no now you were
able to hold somebody over your head oh
dude yes
do you think you could hold me right now
like this no no you're too big look at
it look at it right here what about me
oh yeah probably yeah that'd be fun
it's my friend delaney haircut it's
terrible
he's there in the spot has a banana
bread haircut
what the [ __ ] damn there you go she's a
little thing though
bro that's crazy and then somebody said
i'm like oh yeah okay
let me see that again you know what's so
funny that was the video
that uh where like rogan and i became
friends
because i because he thought i was a
football player when i met him and i was
like no i did cheerleading
watch how both of you guys i mean i'm
trying to see what you're doing here oh
[ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here so she just see i know you
see the national championship
uh banners in the back that's national
i'm yeah see it doesn't say world back
then but that's not my banners
i don't see the world i see the next i'm
a world dude national championship big
deal
look by the way look at him hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on dude this is a dope one
you're sick there though hey how long is
that you're thick there um that was
that was two years ago 2017. damn bro
this one's uh
so that was you so you were doing this
you were playing grab-ass channel this
was the last time i cheered i know the
video's all [ __ ] up but
someone sent it to me
that was 2013 that's the last time i
competed damn look at you that was
worlds that was world
that's worlds yeah you were doing
serious gymnastics yeah
it was so funny every time ah oh come
get some daddy what
um [ __ ] bro oh you were hyped
up look at that [ __ ] back handspring
look at him walking like that
for a guy your size to be moving like
that it's crazy
a guy most guys my size that
don't tumble can't do that not at that
kind of level not up in here
not at all
don't bring that [ __ ] up don't bring
that [ __ ] over here do not tumble on me
do not
hear i could teach you a backflip yeah
but i don't want to teach you a backflip
no i think i was doing one into foam
yeah we've done one phone oh
yeah i could do that
you know what i'd love to do is you and
i were working on a backflip they knew
when you hit the backflip on stage and i
was like oh i'm like
man that's all right i know it's crazy
with the crowd
you gotta practice that and if you're a
little drunk you fall right on your
[ __ ] head yeah dude i used to i used
to do that [ __ ] drunk all the time
yeah but you've been doing it yeah but
that's your language true for you it's
like that i showed up to practice drunk
sometimes that was bad
damn yeah all right what are we doing
today yeah you want me to flip can i
just be like
you show up faded yeah those times i
would i didn't
they call you problem child no they were
just like they literally they're all
scared
they couldn't say [ __ ] to me because are
you the only black guy on the team no no
no no no
no my girlfriend teams like they just
went they just wouldn't say [ __ ] to me
because they're like
i mean this guy [ __ ] he hits
everything he
lands everything yeah yeah yeah mike was
the one who did that for
south florida she she was on the team
for four years she did
she did uh she was the one who did all
the flyers oh hell yeah oh she was the
girl
she was flying because she was a diver
before that social media oh okay yeah
like all that well
she was at jess south florida's back
yeah she did a back handspring backflip
crazy what color software is there are
they green this [ __ ] is crazy man
i don't think we're having a moment
she would know yeah i don't know but she
would flip university of south florida
yeah
is that southern florist north florida
it was southern florida
it's d1 i don't know all those schools
are world champs skateboarder
freaking musical shocker comedian media
you would have been a running back or
something i feel like he's a world
champion
you've never seen a runner could have
been a running back yeah why
do you saw the picture of me at [ __ ]
in high school
look at the picture of me in high school
that picture me in high school that's
that's not a running is that a running
back
that's not right no it's not what the
[ __ ] do you see what i look like he
doesn't even lift he's not even lifting
and look at his
neck and his shoulders are you out of
your mind you sure it says 100 percent
you could have been yeah it's a band god
you're long and lean there yeah
strong because it wasn't there's
yeah yeah you're an easy two hundred i'm
sorry did you say
south florida i wanna go back south
florida east florida south florida all
right
south florida south florida southwest
yeah cause i'm trying to know what that
means but yeah we played
uh we would play them in football yeah
yes we built it
same conference yeah south florida yeah
well best player kind of
florida brandon marshall but when i was
at louisville we were big east
i think they were big east right yeah
and then we went over to acc
that dude patino rick pitino big deal
gosh every time he walks on the court
everybody just be quiet oh yeah
because he's just so [ __ ] up sorry
who's patina
coach rick wittino yeah basketball he
does small school now he got kicked out
for uh oh
there was like some [ __ ] back yeah yeah
yeah looks like mafioso
very mafioso guy come in like this the
sweetest suits
all right the biggest deal he's at some
real small school now yeah that's
kicking ass
he got here though for uh paying players
really but who isn't dude and then the
players went wait we're not supposed to
get paid
the good ones did they wait we're not
supposed to get only good players were
getting paid
yeah yeah he's at iona college what
you'll say chris we're walking a little
bit like a young christopher walken
how dare you you ever seen christopher
walken i might be thinking of the wrong
it's something
i can see i can see where you get that
maybe am i is it the hair no have you
had your brown hair
right yeah maybe it's the hair i i um
yeah i see it
but i i always wanted to be the kind of
guy that had a reason to wear a suit
that was expensive
[ __ ] wear one today i just got paid
for a suit today yeah
for the yeah the mayweather fight yep
you weren't you don't wear suits really
yeah
just don't at your age you could i went
and bought no one
suits and i've never worn them put dude
wear one tomorrow oh shinigami is coming
on tomorrow yeah the [ __ ] what time
are we doing that the
the backyard fighter what time 11 30 30.
all right shinigami
come on i need you to show respect i
will have him kick you in the face yeah
you got to show respect dude we're all
gonna wear headbands by the way i might
go
i might go kick for kick for them and i
haven't kicked in a long time
you go kick wit for with shinigami you
saw the kick a lot of that's taekwondo
stuff let's see what happens
hey do you think i can convince him to
change his nickname street panda by the
time you leave studios
good call how great is it mission
accomplished first of all
who got y'all into shinigami you did
i've been a fan since day one and i calm
street panda so we'll see how that goes
oh he's not stupid he's the reaper let
him have reaper
street panda no all right we're out all
right uh i
am in oklahoma oklahoma city
june 10th through the 12th brickstown
comedy club with the squad david lucas
chappelle lacey
and my boy justin
and then uh we have it's not on here yet
but we have pittsburgh coming up in july
and we have uh rally uh north carolina
as well coming up
and then the only one on there is uh
denver comedy work september 30 through
october 2nd also new thick boy gear
drops friday morning
thickboy.com we have uh all new thick
hoodies
we have thick long sleeves and thick
tees
uh come see me in toledo this weekend
hell yeah funny bone may 28 29th 30th
san antonio texas lol june third fourth
and fifth
mistake you're staying at uh my favorite
hotel dog okay i know
hotel emma hotel this is your daddy
let's see what he can do okay see what
daddy can do i'll see what i can do
favor and do
yeah cause hotel is the [ __ ] i can't say
it anywhere else but emma i love that no
you don't want to stay anywhere no i
love that hotel
that albany new york me and dove david
off david oh hell yeah that's gonna be a
hell of a show i loved
june 18 19 we're driving up together
from new york city
okay to albany new york to do some stand
up for two nights
and philadelphia pa i love that club
helium june 25th
26th 27th get your [ __ ] ticket oh you
should see my guys at suplex and get
shoes get refreshed
oh yeah no no no no but they're the ones
that send me these yeezys man i love
philly as the city though
uh i'll be next week june 4th and 5th
skyline comedy club
in appleton wisconsin and then july 5th
yeah
yeah magooby's
hey have you guys been to lutherville
timoni [ __ ] no oh
is that is that is outside baltimore
yeah i think it's like 19 years flying
to baltimore yeah it's
basically baltimore you say baltimore
but i heard it i heard it's dope
luther revealed i know i i literally
wrote luther i would just put baltimore
dope as [ __ ] even people that live in
lutherville timonium
have no idea what it is
in baltimore
myself f-a-t-k-z.com think boys this
friday morning
aka street panda no reaper
respect that man street reaper is cool
friday right friday
street